today's video is kindly sponsored by
rage shadow legends find out more later
on hey 42 here we all have bad days now
and then when stress builds up and we
don't behave our best
just the other day i found myself
rolling my eyes and muttering under my
breath at another driver on the road and
this morning a politician's comments on
the radio upset me so much i had to put
my cup of tea down quite firmly and
leave the room
i didn't even finish my biscuit but as
shocking as these outbursts may be they
don't hold a candle to more extreme
behavior you know the kinds of things
i'm talking about
rotating your head 360 degrees speaking
in a demonic voice vomiting pea green
liquid all over a priest
if you're the parent of a teenager that
might sound like an average first day
night but of course what i'm actually
referring to here are the scenes from
the exorcist one of the most iconic
horror films of all time in case you
haven't seen it in the exorcist 12 year
old regan is more than a little bit
stressed out and poorly behaved she's
possessed by satan himself
the normally sweet and delightful regan
turns violent and foul-mouthed develops
tremendous strength and becomes the
epicenter of swirling and destructive
supernatural forces
scary stuff
but in the end it's all just a bunch of
hollywood nonsense right
well
catholic priest father walter halloran
would probably have partially agreed
with you on that he said a lot of what
appeared in the film was inaccurate and
exaggerated
but not because he thought the idea of a
child being possessed by the lord of
darkness was far-fetched
it was more that the events depicted in
the film didn't happen quite how he
remembered them
now if you haven't assembled an alliance
of champions and commanded them for
arena battles dungeon runs then what are
you doing with your life because you're
missing out on the greatest mobile game
of all time raid shadow legends
remember you can use my links below to
download raid yourself to your mobile
phone or pc so i've been playing great
for a while now and i've tried my luck
against some of the most difficult
bosses in the game but everything is
about to change
the newest boss coming to raid is the
biggest and craziest yet
this thing is a hydra with six different
heads one of the heads the head of
blight is a nasty one it leaches your
team whilst protecting its own then
there's the head of raft that gets angry
it gets so angry it gives itself a scary
buff vengeance that triples its attack
power there's so much to discover in
raid but personally i really enjoy the
pvp arena it's a great way to put all of
my experience during the raid campaign
to good use against other players raid's
also giving away a super limited edition
champion to every player in the game
it's esports legend and navi superstar
simple between now and january the 28th
2022 simple's limited edition champ is
available for free to both new and old
players in raid all you have to do is
log in for seven days and he's yours
there's seriously never been a better
time to get started hit the link in the
description below or scan my qr code and
you'll get an epic champion rector
giraffe 200k silver one energy refill
and one xp boost and one ancient shard
all this treasure will be waiting for
you here but be quick because all these
rewards will only be available for 30
days
once you're in you can find me in game
under the name 42 and if you're fast you
can join my clan and it's that easy just
click the link in the description and
i'll see you in game
you see the inspiration for the exorcist
didn't come from a screenwriter's
imagination
it came from real life events
our story begins in 1940s america in
cottage city maryland a 12 13 or 14 year
old boy depending on which account you
read is mourning the sudden and
unexpected loss of his beloved aunt
harriet
the boy he would later become known by
the pseudonyms roland's doe or robbie
mannheim had been particularly close to
harriet an active spiritualist
spiritualism is the belief that people
who die pass into the spirit world where
they can still be contacted by the
living via a medium or a device like a
ouija board along with the practices of
her faith harriet had taught roland how
to use this tool and together they had
tried to contact departed souls
when harriet died in 1949 roland was
devastated and reports suggest he tried
to contact her through his ouija board
whether he was successful or not is
unknown but it seemed he contacted
something
because it was around that time that
things began to go wrong for roland and
his family the does began to hear
strange sounds throughout the house
including marching feet muffled voices
and scratching noises emanating from the
walls and floors
furniture moved by itself and objects
levitated
without warning water began dripping
from pipes and most terrifying of all
roland's mattress began to move around
of its own accord like the world's least
fun magic carpet
roland also began to change before
harriet's death he'd been a quiet
reserved boy but in the time after her
death his behavior became increasingly
erratic with roland acting aggressively
towards those around him for no apparent
reason he also started to develop marks
and scratches all over his body
seemingly out of nowhere we know about
these events thanks to an anonymous
source who submitted a series of reports
that ended up in several american
newspapers in mid-1949
that person was later identified as the
dove family's former pastor the reverend
luther miles shules
in these articles schulz described how
the doe family had taken roland to see
medical doctors and psychiatrists but
that no one had any idea what the hell
was wrong with him
schulz then arranged to observe roland
overnight and claim to have experienced
a range of effects that he attributed to
dark forces
scratching noises coming from the walls
and vibrating sounds coming from
roland's bed
blankets allegedly moved around the room
and furniture tipped over untouched
it was at that point that schulz a
protestant preacher suggested the family
prepare roland for an exorcism
but for that they were going to need to
bring the big guns
the catholic church
exorcism which involves evicting demons
or other spiritual nasties that have
taken up residence inside a human being
or a place
has a long and varied history across
many cultures and religions from islam
to hinduism buddhism and judaism in the
west exorcism is closely related to the
history of christianity especially
catholicism although the practice
apparently goes all the way back to
jesus who according to the bible
performed an exorcism on a
demon-possessed boy the vatican first
issued official guidelines on exorcism
in 1614
updating them as recently as 1999
as well as these rules the vatican has a
small list of officially approved
exorcists around the world
but most ordained catholic priests can
get permission to perform the ritual if
they so desire
one such person was father edward hughes
a roman catholic priest who judged that
roland was the victim of demonic
possession
according to hughes one telltale sign
was that roland couldn't keep his eyes
off the bible
not exactly csi level evidence i admit
but apparently it was good enough for
father hughes according to the us
conference of catholic bishops you can
tell if someone is demonically possessed
because they have a superhuman strength
an aversion to holy water or the ability
to speak in unknown languages other
potential signs include spitting cursing
and excessive masturbation which pretty
much accounts for my entire class in
secondary school but there you go
hughes recommended that roland be taken
to georgetown university hospital where
he was kept for free nights whilst hugh
performed a series of exorcisms on him
according to father hughes those three
nights were filled with unnatural events
and the process was eventually stopped
when roland broke free from the
restraints holding him to the bed
snapped off a bedspring and used it to
slash open the priest's arm
after that the family took roland home
where things went from bad to worse
red scratches started to appear on the
boy's body with one set of marks
spelling out the word louie
since roland's mother and her sister
harriet were originally from saint louis
in missouri
roland's parents decided the demon
wanted the family to move there
luckily for them the scratches hadn't
spelt out greenland otherwise who knows
how the story would have ended as you've
probably guessed things weren't much
better in saint louis and the family had
to go back to the church for help
the first person they spoke to was
father raymond bishop the priest he will
go on to keep a diary of events
surrounding roland doe's apparent
possession
father bishop signed up a colleague
reverend william bowden and the two of
them visited though at home where they
claimed to have seen objects flying
around the room a shaking bed and roland
speaking in a guttural voice the
archbishop granted permission for
bowdoin to perform an exorcism on roland
and the boy was ultimately moved to the
psychiatric ward of the alexian brothers
hospital in south saint louis
there bowdoin was joined by another
priest walter halloran who supported him
in the exorcism
the process went on for several weeks
with the priests performing exorcisms on
the boy every night
why does something about that sentence
make me feel iffy
according to halloran during the time
words such as evil and hell along with
other marks like a pitchfork appeared on
the teenager's body roland doe was also
described as having the strength of a
fully grown man and at one point he
broke father hollowan's nose he also
hurled abuses at the priests threatened
them with violence and offered them
sexual favors which just sounds like my
local pub on a saturday night the ritual
of exorcism was performed on the boy
over 30 times before the priest decided
to shift gears and baptized roland
accounts claimed that this was a turning
point and that roland doe started acting
like archangel michael shouting satan i
am now michael and i command you to
leave this boy now
which kind of sounds like the priest had
only succeeded in guessing roland
possessed by something else but
apparently that was deemed good enough
the boy known as roland's dough returns
to his senses and went on to live a long
and fulfilling life
untroubled by the irritations of demonic
possession
decades later author william peter
blatty recalled the newspaper reports
he'd read about rolando and used them as
inspiration for his 1971
best-selling novel the exorcist
that book went on to inspire an even
more successful film of the same name
but the question that remains is
was the story true
even if we factor in the undeniable
sensationalism that's included in the
book and film
do the accounts told by reverend
schulze's newspaper interviews and
father bishop's diary holds even a shred
of truth
well the answer to that question really
comes down to whether or not you believe
in demons possession and exorcisms
if you do there's really not a lot to be
said
people and places can be possessed by
dark spirits and when they are crazy
happens but if you take a slightly
more skeptical view
then if we're being honest
it's all a little bit hard to believe
researchers and writers investigating
the roland doe case have perhaps
unsurprisingly arrived at the universal
conclusion that there was nothing
supernatural about the boy he was either
a manipulative teenager literally
raising hell or more likely just a
deeply disturbed child
which sadly is all too common when it
comes to so-called exorcisms the history
of exorcism is littered with examples of
people with a misunderstood mental
illness being subjected to rights and
rituals aimed at saving them from
demonic possession
as recently as 2003 an autistic boy in
milwaukee died after being tied up in
sheets and held down by church members
trying to exercise the evil spirits they
blamed for his condition
an autopsy found that he died of
asphyxiation
then in 2005 at a covenant in romania a
23 year old schizophrenic nun by the
name of maracia arena cornisi
said she'd heard the devil telling her
she was sinful
with the help of four other nuns a
priest performed an exorcism on carnesi
that included binding her to a cross
gagging her with a towel and leaving her
for three days without food or water
she eventually died from a combination
of a lack of oxygen and dehydration
and on christmas day in 2010 in london a
14 year old boy was beaten and drowned
by relatives
trying to free him from the clutches of
an evil spirit
the vatican itself acknowledges that
only a small percentage of exorcism
cases are what it describes as authentic
whatever the hell that means
in the case of roland doe even father
holleran who was heavily involved in the
exorcism refused to go on record as
confirming that doe had been demonically
possessed
during his investigation into the
background of rolando's story author
mark opsinick
found that most of the details were
based on nothing more than hearsay and
were never fact checked
there was no evidence for example that
the first priest father hughes ever
visited rolando's house or performed an
exorcism on the boy the documentation
around the case is also thin and
one-sided relying mainly on testimonials
of two priests both of whom were
believers in demonic possession and the
power of exorcism
to quote the original trailer for the
exorcist
somewhere between science and
superstition there is another world
a world of darkness
but whether you believe that world is
dark because it's governed by satan or
because someone had forgotten to pay the
electricity bill
is really just a question of faith
thanks for watching